there's a there's an attack on new
atheist yeah as I understand it new
atheist pretty much are just atheists
who are finally speaking up about
atheism it may be a little more you you
define it I think a little more
specifically right in the book there's a
little more about that they're actually
trying to shoot down some ideas where an
old atheist maybe just remove themselves
from the discussion is that fair yeah I
mean different people define in
different ways Austin Daye see some
people think there's no difference
between new and the old I think I do
think there is a difference I think
they're a little more kind of forthright
in their speech and people interpret
being forthright as being disrespectful
or overly aggressive I think that's a
mischaracterization I think that they've
made this the additional move from these
this set of beliefs or this suite of
beliefs is irrational to these beliefs
are delusional
and I think from in my work delusion has
been a component of how I I think is
helpful to think about the problem and
but they don't take too kindly to that
the believer a believer the average
believer and you say you're delusional
they're usually not that responsive yeah
if you do that you haven't read the book
because you never you don't want to
invoke a defensive posture and something
I want to enter into a conversation
which people change their beliefs from
point of view of safety yeah so this is
literally what you do in the book I mean
you lay out the exact tools on how you
should talk design by line without the
word yeah there's a template that you
can use and people have gone around this
one Anthony Magna Bosco has gone around
videos on YouTube who implements the
uses the scientific method what is your
confidence in this belief gives an
intervention based upon the book now
what is your in a post-test pretest
intervention postive and it's amazing
the the the down moves that people make
and only 5 to 10 minutes so we know that
this works we know that this is
effective we know that these sorts of
very civil very engaging and that's your
thing you never have to worry about
anybody saying they don't want to talk
about their faith everybody loves let's
look the one thing that people will that
the one commonality among people of
faith they love to talk
so speaking of talking about it I also
hit upon how people are very selective
in what they believe and if you get them
to admit well I don't believe that this
or that happened right I don't believe
some heart you know about chopping off
hands or kind of head that's that's the
crazy part right but I believe in this
other stuff but I think what you were
saying is that basically if you can get
them to sort of start admitting
something not true that's sort of how
you pulled a string right to then
leading to getting them to admit some
other stuff right yeah and and a lot of
that is you have to create conditions
and and again this isn't me there's a
long body of literature there's a long
line of literature about how to change
the behavior of people who don't want
their behavior change it's from drug and
alcohol counseling it's from you know
motivational interviewing cult exiting
this is out there but nobody has really
synthesized it I know it has brought
these disparate elements together so I
was partly thinking this when I was
reading the book what would you what
would you say is the problem if there's
the average person that's a believer
that uses religion for community you
know celebrate some holidays what
whatever the religion might be but isn't
doing anything you know not not people
that are beheading people but if you're
just some average person that doesn't
necessarily take your faith seriously
but you get some sense of community
whatever it is do you see an inherent
problem in that or is that just for you
it's like well you're just sort of
deluded but all right go with it I do
see a problem because I think that
people are wasting their life energy on
something that's not true
they they're harboring a belief about
reality that is almost definitely false
and we just know this empirically
because of the number of different
religions that make different claims
about the world they can't all be right
in fact they're contradictions perfect
one Jesus was crucified Jesus was not
crucified Islam Christianity Mohammed
was the last prophet Mohammed was a
prophet for Mormons
so people are harboring views about
reality that aren't true the other thing
is I've heard people say that a lot and
I have to channel I have to push back
with you and something I'm not so sure
that people can hold a private belief
I'm not so sure that somebody can have a
belief
had not have that belief bleed out into
action hmm not necessarily by speaking
it but just by the way they are can you
give me an example well that that's what
it means to hold a belief yeah I would
say so like I I don't like people I'm
thinking about homosexuality but that's
to charge so I'm going to use your
blazer like I don't like guys who is a
nice blazer coming I would have Brooks
Brothers I'm just gonna make that I
don't like guys who have Brooks blows
but if I can't stand it smelled if they
look different you know but but I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna let that I'm not
going to show like if I meet something I
can work with someone who has a blazer I
can I think what it means that that's
almost a denial of what it means to have
a belief to hold a belief about
something so so I'm also not sure that
these beliefs are benign as people think
that they are and every time I bring
that up people will bring out a study
well look at this like you know
religiosity in this group correlated the
smart people will say correlated the
less intellectually adjoined people will
say you know some causal correlated okay
whatever it's a huge difference but
let's just go with it
look what happens you have religion you
have lower incidence of heart disease or
whatever it is I think the word you used
before was app it's community those
benefits can be found from community and
you can get communities of like-minded
people without believing any
superstitious silliness yeah you know
you can get you can go like the same
sports team I mean yeah and and I think
that
you say well what's the harm with
someone rooting for the patron I don't
know anything about football what's the
harm is someone working for the Patriots
well that that that's dis analogous
because you're not claiming that it's
objectively true right and so if I think
that the Patriots are ordained by God to
win the Super Bowl or whatever it is
that they do you know again I don't know
anything about sports good you linga
thanks Super Bowl well don't take me
down that road being trouble and then I
get fifty hate mails people love
football yeah so so I think that the
problem is that people make objective
claims and they live their lives
accordingly
and this is all you got man Zed Zed so
wouldn't it be better for those people
to be invited to see reality for what it
is wouldn't it be better to give those
people an opportunity to flourish
because if your beliefs
if one belief it's like you can look at
it is like an architectonic truck like a
big building right if one of your
beliefs on the bottom level of that
building it's contaminated like a base
belief like Jesus rose from the dead
order then all of the beliefs that flow
from that or stem from that become
suspect so if you if you so what's the
harm the harm is that if you want to
enable yourself to flourish and you want
to enable your community to flourish you
have to align your beliefs with reality
because if you don't then what you think
is objectively moral the right thing to
do will actually be leading you away
from flourishing right so that's
interesting so almost in a way you then
systemically you have to constantly be
compromising because no matter how much
new evidence comes in to prove something
else
you really have to skirt around it
because you've built sort of your your
base in things that aren't yeah and you
put your finger on the cognitive problem
the cognitive problem is then in order
to reconcile that they make a virtue out
of not revising their beliefs they make
a sin then you need to import new words
words that have words that are anathema
to belief revision like sin like sacred
and that buttresses or protects those
beliefs from being revised
so there's a whole mechanism to keep
this that in almost like I talked about
in a book it's it's almost if you look
at it epidemiologically how these things
spread like memes they spread mimetic
Allah when you really think about that
the harm is that literally billions of
people are living in ways that they
think is just and kind and right and
it's not and nation-states are created
around that and we are in a very serious
problem with technology and the
instantaneous flow of and
axis of information we are in a problem
that we can no longer afford not only to
ignore that but to disallow here we go
the regressive left is to go but to
disallow conversations about those
things we look a shocking number of
people in this country and I'm ashamed
to say this but that doesn't don't shoot
the messenger
yeah do not want Muslim immigration they
want to target people and not their
beliefs we need to have a talk about
that
yeah ignoring that is not only not going
to make it go away but it's going to
make that percentage increase and that's
the thing that the regressives just
cannot seem to understand right so and
of course we're back to it but all right
no but it's okay so the but the point
being that so then if you were to take
someone like Sam who's having extremely
difficult complex thought-out
conversations about the difference
between Islam and Muslims and Islamism
and jihad and all those things and if
you put him in the same Bank as Trump
there is nobody left I think that for me
Zach that for me is why I've taken this
so that I've taken this thing on because
I saw this yeah I who I told Sam to his
face I didn't even know who he was
before that right believe it or not I
didn't really know I didn't follow him
on Twitter I had never read any of his
books I had maybe heard of him but I
watched that thing and I thought Jesus
here's a guy trying to tell the truth on
some pretty controversial things and
look at the way he's being passed and
even trying to ask questions and that's
what's so interesting and that's what
you moral look it's complicated moral
arguments are just complicated that's
why you have guys very smart individuals
who have substantive disagreements about
you know eating animals factored form
this is complicated but that's more
reason and not less reason to talk about
it and what they've done to Sam is that
they have created conditions to make it
impossible for people to speak yeah they
have really done exactly the opposite of
what so that's the danger of what's
going on in the colleges really because
you're we're using Sam as one example at
this but if they can breed that ideology
in the colleges now it goes to what you
were saying before you worry about the
future because now you're going to bring
up all these people with with all this
idea so is someone
though that to have these conversations
first off people we view things on vine
in six seconds on 140 characters and I'm
really happy to be doing long-form again
and I really do believe it's coming back
and I get emails every day something
that people are digging it so we're onto
something but it's part of it that to
have real discussions about real things
and especially when you take when you do
it from the religious angle and atheism
and all that well you know basically
Bill Maher and Dawkins and a couple
other people that are really in the
limelight of it and that you're putting
too much on a few people and that's sort
of the reverse of how this should go if
you want to have real open discussion
right yeah you're putting a lot on a few
people and for example it's art never
but for example people always I'll
defend Bill Maher in related to this and
people say well he's sort of a dick
about it and he's thrown in and
everyone's face and all that but I'll
always say well I grant him a leash on
this because he's fighting the good
fight in my view he's fighting something
that's so hard to do and really using
reason to explain complex things so I
have to if he's a little bit of a dick
about it all right it's what there's
plenty of dicks all the others I do yeah
it's interesting and again I think again
a flix respect clip was just perfect a
flex response was so implemented now I
don't know if Rogen's right I have no
idea if this guy such a good actor he
had as all believe it I really I can't I
don't I don't know the answer to that
but I do know is that that reaction is
more typical than ever now and we need
less of that reaction here's one way
that we may want to think about getting
less of that reaction and I'm not being
facetious when I tell us any incredibly
sincere virtually every time I speak to
someone not every time you know if
they're a professional apologist and
that goes out the window
virtually every time excuse me when I'm
speaking with someone I always think to
myself maybe they know something I don't
know and if you can just attempt to hold
that in your head in I have found in
conversations with religious people
that's been very helpful I will admit to
you I almost cannot do that any longer
with the regressives yeah because
because they make a slip of the tongue
into just some monstrous heinous act or
I always feel that it's personal like
it's deeply personal like there's
something there's something in me that
they need to you know cleanse or
something like there's some kind of like
well that's what I mean about the
authoritarian thing like they're in a
weird way they're doing religious
trickery they are doing yet yeah they're
the horseshoe they're buying yeah
they're using a lot of the tactics so
the question is like what do we do how
do we engage these people I mean this is
a very this is a very difficult question
particularly when they now have at their
disposal they've been there they have
infested academia you know like what do
we do when these people are now the rule
makers well it's interesting that the
more I try to bring this towards atheism
the more it comes back to this because
it seems to me that they're there the
attacks that they've done on the new
atheist where they use it as a
pejorative now you're a new atheist it's
sort of some sort of evil creature even
though I don't know many I don't know
anyone really that identifies as a new
atheist as a I don't think me out of
maybe Sam does I'm not even sure I don't
I did but they've just muddied the water
you were just saying you don't identify
as an atheist right oh yeah I mean you
could attempt to smear me you can
attempt to but the irony is I Joe and I
talked about this it's like I have never
heard the person used the word
intersectional who wasn't just a nasty
who wasn't just a really just
mean-spirited angry person yeah and so
and I think that is part of the of
course I should be indignant because I'm
a good person good people become
indignant at these things yeah so okay
we're gonna talk about atheism yeah
we're gonna go okay let's go this is fun
we're gonna do so what kind of chart
could we do on this I just trying I'm
reading it back yeah I know I know
you're going with me so I think part of
the problem is also that when people
have made the choice to make the leap of
faith right whatever the religion that
they've jumped in in a certain way even
though I think in their eyes they're
doing something very lofty and in a
certain way you're doing you're just I
do it as sort of like you're giving up
sort of you're like this the world is a
pretty [ __ ] up place I don't know the
answer so I'm just going
leap and just hope that this so is that
is that part of why it makes the
rational person's argument to them very
difficult because they're you're you're
arguing against something that's not
rational in its most pure form that I
did I get somewhere there yeah I don't
know only because I think different
people believe for different reasons and
so I I don't know I here's what I do
know unlike this belief that seems to be
memeing out everywhere seems to be going
around you can actually reason people on
out of unreasonable positions in fact I
was just talking to my buddy that's a
couple days ago John W Loftus I wrote
the foreword to his new book he was a
disciple of the greatest Christian
apologist after he reasoned it's of
Jerry DeWitt the list goes on and on if
people who have done that and I think it
doesn't start with reason so much it
starts with honesty you really think
there was a talking snake like it like
no [ __ ] like you think but yet if
you looked at your garden and you're
waking up and a snakes are talking to
you you'd be freaking out right so
tonight nobody would believe you and no
one was alive you right so these things
Co here in a very complicated not to use
a big word but covariant set of beliefs
that reinforce other beliefs etc etc so
I don't think that there's we can narrow
down to one node or one data point for
why people believe I think it's a very
complex equation yeah you know it's
funny I haven't thought of this so
literally until just the second but
years ago I think in 1997 so I was 21 I
went to Egypt and I was at Mount Sinai
which is supposedly where Moses got the
Ten Commandments and I hiked up the
mountain it's a long hike you're
supposed to do it at night I did it
during the day I ran out of water I mean
I was basically delusional my stomach
was messed up for my ate some bad pigeon
in Cairo I mean I was if I was if there
was ever a moment where I was gonna have
a spiritual awakening like that's where
it was because I was compromised in my
body right and I remember I'm not
hitting at all I mean I remember going
to the top of that thing and thinking
like if if there's something here mmm
you got to give me a sign right like if
there's something here and this is where
Moses supposedly saw the burning bush
and got the Ten Commandments and all
that then you
to give me something there was nothing
so for me that was sort of like Oh God
God's very good hiding yeah great hider
this guy yeah yeah and I think that
that's kind of I mean if you really
think about this I apologize ahead of
time if this lowers your IQ by a couple
points no geez peep people will say well
that's why you need faith because there
is no evidence or there is no there's
nothing for God you just have to have
faith in that but you don't act that way
in any other aspect of your life like
you know there's no other arena and that
in which you think like that right can I
can't go back to you and your friend
again yeah yeah
cuz I still thinking about this so what
if you had another belief that had
nothing to do with Muslims or Islam that
that friend found odious they would
probably let it slide I think that's
where you're going that's right I'm
going yeah what I'm that's what I'm
amazed about this whole thing this seems
to be the one sticking point at a shaken
so what is that okay so so that's an
opportunity I'll tell you what that is
that's an opportunity for your friend to
reflect to sincerely reflect about the
moral priority that she or he has given
this one issue and to ask yourself well
does that seem just as an outsider as an
outsider does that seem that that this
one issue should trump everything else
because I'm frankly I don't even know if
I'm concerned about their well-being
like I'm concerned about their well
priorities
well that was also part when we were
having this discussion which again was
on text we also felt so we have it felt
like nothing you know when you're having
a little conversation with someone and
you can feel weight to it and you can
feel important to do it over text felt
ridiculous I'm not even email which also
wouldn't have felt great now but I could
not get this person to sit down with me
that there would have been nothing else
and that's your point there would be
nothing else and when I said well is
there evidence of this what have I ever
in all that the time that you've known
me right it was
secretly doing this yep so here's the
thing that I've been thinking about the
thing that I try to be careful of I've
been noticing it's like I sometimes if
somebody has a belief that's just so out
in left field it's really easy for me
and I try to rein myself in with this
internal tendency I don't verbalize it
articulated and thinking these people
have mental disorders like it's very you
know you know and then I'll talk to
people who you know believe in actual
talking snakes and such we ain't again
they very nice people are very easy to
talk to I debated a guy and Perth in it
I still keep in touch with them written
to each other there is something about
literally believes that he talks to
snakes know in talking snakes like in
the Bible Oh will you talking you know
look at that he did him yeah no no no
that's a whole different level of person
I think yeah that that is and it's it's
it's very difficult from for me Dave I
try not to characterize people whose
beliefs are so far afield of mine that
they have mental disorders and I find I
think I find the type of people who go
into religion are the sort of people who
tend to be imbalanced anyway and they
find a nice community for that a way to
discharge those bizarre beliefs it's the
same thing with the regressives are we
supposed to keep talking about any other
yeah it's that they find this wonderful
social justice warrior place where they
can be behind their keyboard and angry
and smear people they get along I hate
it all the rage and they and it's very
difficult for me to rein myself in and
not write them all off as people who
have mental disorders and I'm that's
part of my work man I'm trying
I hear you in the most that I can
possibly hear someone I hear you and
that's why I find it exhausting and it
is exact I wonder so for you even before
the regressive thing took hold so much
this discussion a discussion about you
know free thinking and critical thinking
verse faith alright and things you can't
prove and then you toss in some of the
regressives right how exhausting is this
for you on a day-to-day basis because
I do find that it can be extremely
exhausting that at the end of the day I
can have trouble shutting off my mind or
I'll wake up at 6:00 and I click on
Twitter and then I immediately see
craziness before I've gotten out of bed
and I do find it sort of exhausting what
about for you yeah I think that's
because you care a lot and I don't
really care about like the negative
things people say I really don't I mean
I legitimately don't I have pressing
things that I care about my family and
my health friendships you know
relationships and I don't but I guess in
a sense I'm genuinely interested in what
people believe and why they believe it
and how it's possible to hold
preposterous beliefs so it's just
praying parentally interesting to me
what's problematic though and what is
exhausting are the constant ways that I
self-censor because I'm afraid of
academic punishment are the constant
lean I just had another complaint filed
against me in the ways that I can't and
it's not that the administration has
said anything to me it's the culture in
which we're the academic culture now is
you you just have to be extremely
cautious about what you say particularly
regard to Islam or particularly
regardless there are certain thing you
don't have to be conscious whatsoever if
you want to criticize Big Pharma you can
just it's your thing like in the class
you can say [ __ ] [ __ ] you can say
they're gonna but don't use a pronoun
wrong or don't say you know don't slip
again 49 with the [ __ ] word I don't do
that anymore but you know the things
that are exhausting to me are the
mechanisms that are in place that
prohibit the free expression of ideas
and not necessarily that I don't have
tenure and I'll never get tenure not
necessarily that anything it would be a
career ender but it is a theft of my
time it is now I have to constantly go
you know deal with it and I have to have
it in the back of my mind and then oh if
I say something else I have another
complaint and then I'll be the guy who
gets all these complaints so it's
working within these and you know the
other thing I was thinking about last
night is that what this does in essence
is it pushes the whole system towards
mediocrity it pushes the whole system
because then people are afraid
to voice controversial ideas or opinions
or give sides that students wouldn't
hear they want to be the people who
don't get complaints filed against them
so they take the evil the the easy they
take the easy easy courses you know and
and what they're not talking about is
like for example nothing to do with
regressive left but or and cognitive
disability and its challenge tomorrow
flaws were to read a great book about
that we're not talking about the status
Peter Singer has really interesting
stuff about this philosopher of what
should the status of cognitively
disabled people be and he says they
should be more equivalent in treatment -
I don't want to mischaracterize him but
- to basically pigs and cows I think
that that's an important conversation to
have and the whole system is then being
pushed towards mediocrity
because professors don't want to deal
with it they don't they just can't the
stomach or handle all these ridiculous
student complaints so they just don't
teach it yeah why are you never going to
get tenure
oh I was told that I could publish ten
books from Harvard and I never get
tenure
it was like the best thing that ever
happened to the moment after this guy
might I won't say who is this person
told me this I wrote an article like
well okay well since I'm never ending a
tenner and I know that there's nothing I
can do independent of my accomplishments
I'll never get promoted I
it just felt was the most freeing
feeling ever I left his office and I
wrote a little piece suddenly I
published something like what should the
role of the educator be and I said that
the role of the educator should be to
change students beliefs if they're not
in alignment with reality students can
be totally in controversial my
colleagues freaked out about it the
piece went viral this is brief how this
out chronology and this how I got in
touch with Sam Harris and then I some
guy from Paul party from philosophy News
said you want to do a podcast and when
the podcast sam harris tweeted we need
more educators like peter Boghossian
that's how i got in touch with Dawkins
Dawkins tweeted it and that that just
started this whole cascade but I have
never felt more free to talk about
anything that I want knowing that I
could be fired at any instant I love
that actually it's a freedom that I
relish well I love it I love it
because it shows you the importance of
ideas which is really that's the big
thing here that everything else is
couched in right that you had an idea
you shared it and then your idea was
shared by people that you respect and
admire who you credit in your book for
helping you get to this place and then
they spread an idea and that I guess to
sort of bring this all around is what
the regressives are fearing and that's
why they want to silence everyone
because they don't like they don't like
your ideas right so that they're not
going to debate them yeah they don't
like it
they think they have the truth it is
really a bizarre kind of epistemological
myopia not even it's just that they have
these ideas that they're completely
convinced or true again like religion
holding them makes them better people
their sacrosanct
you can't criticism not only can you
can't even ask about it can't even ask
how they derived it right because if you
do you're a big interlaces and they're
so morally sure a lot of sanctimonious I
guess that's why I wanted to bring this
around to relate it to religion because
I've been trying to put this all
together yeah and there is these
underpinnings that are so the same of
the authoritarian religious thing it's
it's all there it really is all there
it's like they hate really there on the
left they hate religion terrestrial 1
hey Christianity right but they have one
religion that they want to protect right
because it's it's the town crowd and
religions but and then just everything
they do is in it's a constant shell game
they're just moving the goal posts all
the time and how intellectually
exhausting must that be for them I don't
think it's that tiring for them well
because they're just so in genuine and
diss yeah since that's what I've come to
believe because many people every day I
get email people saying why don't you
sit down with one of these guys and
there's you know there's a list of the
public ones that I could sit down with
right I know some of them personally and
it's like what could we do you know if I
if they've been exposed repeatedly as
Liars as they have and as repeatedly
like we've had intentions so then for
you for you someone that deals in the
moral landscape without religion right
and heals and critical thinking what
what should the decision process be for
me you know because I think about all
the time yeah I guess I could do it like
okay so here's a piece of my friend
Jerry Coyne said this to me very
Ellucian or biologists very useful piece
of information like somebody trying to
say this without pumping this giving
this person any identity but here's what
I think you should do give the piece
advice you give me yeah people are going
to criticize you no matter what so if
someone says to you hey you know I'm
going to donate to charity I'm gonna do
this the question I think is do you
think that this person is sincere and
honest in their engagement with you not
what would I get out of it not what
would they get out of it not even what
would it do to further the discourse but
is this a sincere person who's willing
to sit down and talk with me and look at
the evidence and are their beliefs
defeasible are they willing so you know
hey look Dave I came in here I thought
this I had a conversation with you but
equally important you have to ask that
of yourself right and if that is absent
from that discourse it's just a farce so
why would you you should right should
never listen to someone though on
Twitter you're gonna have this it will
[ __ ] you like you have it your own show
yeah no you should devilís - you're not
held hostage to the irrationality of
others yeah I like that that's a good
ending that sounds like a good ending we
could have done so much more you know
and I pretty much I could have just
mixed these up I don't even know that I
really looked at him but I could have
just thrown them all over I'm dying to
know it's on okay you can have those all
right we will absolutely do this again
and then we'll and and I won't bring any
of those cards and we'll just see see
what happens but the beauty of this is
that this this is big and this is what a
lot of people have wanted to talk about
and I like the fact that I'm able to
talk about it with people that are
dealing with it in different ways so at
the academic level on the religious
level or belief level and then people
are dealing at the political level and
all and you've been a catalyst I mean
you've brought people together you've
talked about an issue that's important
more and more people are becoming aware
of that and you'd be kind of you've
become a figure in which people go to
and they look to and they respect for
these sorts of conversations to help
them navigate these difficult terrains
because these are not easy issues
they're particularly not easy when again
a lot of the arguments that people on
the regressive the regressive have they
really should be taken earnest
you know treating people not treating
people differently in the basis of skin
coming these are really important things
and we need to be sensitive to how we
behave we need to be more kind and more
just and more compassionate the way to
do that is not through the regressives
the way to do that is by being honest
and sincere with ourselves and having
these sorts of discourses having these
kind of dialogues I want to thank Peter
Bogosian for joining me you can check
out his work at Peterborough ENCOM and
by a manual for creating atheists
wherever books are sold
thanks for watching and we will do it
again next week